lang états sont des passoires doucement
va pas être trop droite en haut c'est ok
ce n'est pas ce rendez vous comme les
autres aujourd'hui pour kevin il est ici
pour effacer son tatouage de confort
très vite et assez au wat et titre au
concours pas vertige on est parti by
poisson c'était un ami qui s'est
produite à thouars qui me dit je
pourrais faire un tatoo fait léger match
des jeunes se jetait pour ce premier
side
je connais pas ce que ça peu que les
procédures je ne sais pas à ce moment on
est à reims perd un bras complètement
black out
c'est une façon assez haute cour de
faire un cover des clients comme lui
stéphanie en a de plus en plus on a
vraiment vu une hausse dès qu'on appelle
nous aurons un bon genre jargon à dota
toile des scratchs jusqu aux gens sans
formation officielle reconnue
de plus en plus de gens s'improvisent
tatouage en achetant en ligne des kits
pour débutants les prix varient mais
pour une centaine de dollars vous pouvez
recevoir des pistolets à tatouages des
aiguilles plusieurs types d'encre variés
bref tout l'équipement nécessaire une
machine à tatouage régulière qu'on peut
se procurer sur wii on va voir ça sur
qu'à 15 $ une machine professionnelle
on n'a pas ça en bois de 500 $ le fait
que le prix est chip
c'est comme si je vous avais je vous
envoie acheter un kit d'outils chez
dollarama pour réparer votre voiture que
le résultat va être malheureusement
digne d'un dollar à mort moi
personnellement je toucherai pas ça
je recommanderais pas non plus à
personne de toucher à ces produits le ne
sachant pas qui est ce qui se cache
derrière avec le phénomène du colloque
date pas de cette année c'est sûr
qu'avec la pandémie on a vu une
augmentation
jean-françois there un salon tatouage
depuis dix ans il connaît bien cette
industrie
on n'a pas de législation n'impose aux
professionnels de t3 c'est vraiment un
de même son tour et hull arih mais
chacun le fait personnellement c'est
dangereux selon moi oui
la plupart des provinces canadiennes
encadre cette profession mais au québec
ce n'est pas le cas le ministère de la
santé indique que selon les études le
risque d'infection en lien avec le
tatouage et surtout relié à des
pratiques et artisanal qui échapperaient
de toute façon à un encadrement par une
réglementation du côté de santé canada
des lois et règlements existent ils sont
surtout reliés à l'utilisation des
encres de tatouage
les établissements doivent s'assurer que
le produit ne présente aucun risque
mais y at-il assez de normes entourant
le matériel acheté sur le web s'est
vendu en ligne
ils peuvent prendre le contrôle là
dessus que ce qui arrive dans une boîte
aux frontières ils peuvent pour vérifier
chaque colis il est d'angers ce sont les
risques d'infection et de contamination
on peut s'infecter avec un virus comme
l'hépatite par exemple si les
il n'est pas prêt il peut y avoir
justement une contamination
directement implanté dans la peau il
peut avoir le produit aussi qui est
contaminée qu'on va injecter à
l'intérieur qui contaminés par les
bactéries qu'ils contaminées par des
virus docteur barreau laisse sait de
quoi il parle il développe de nouvelles
technologies au laser pour effacer les
tatouages depuis des décennies vraiment
c'est pas de long qui est fait pour les
humains ainsi vendus parfois sur les
marchés comme ça peut mettre n'importe
quoi vivent au prix le plus bas
donc il faut prendre de longues comme je
disais tantôt qui vient d'autres
domaines comme les imprimantes pour
éviter le pire
les amateurs de tatouage doivent être
bien informé s'il ya des tatouages sont
un amas ganic et on approchera envoyé au
laser puis des tatouages qui virent
tellement mal qu'on les envoie locale
parce que les infections sont trop
grandes
selon moi ce qu'il faudrait faire c'est
plus d'éducation c'est sûr que si on en
parle au port c'est sûr que là il
pourrait avoir des dérapages
il y en a actuellement on le voit ici
marie michel lauzon radio canada
montréal